андрей ви маєте поруб
синівший українець і нам сьогодні і дуже
важливо свій будинок це все статичним
це crimean змінилися та їх не буду
заміні україна моя тобою знову tedx
алібасів українців і суті ви прийшло
яхті астана російського світу якийсь перу
є з кременя я тіло партія торговим
завданням з небіль вати
злиднів і 100 лише призначення революції
зерна steam великі і дістають ват
грою та майдану добровольцем герой мотор
зайву всіх до джанаки
і в жирик ми в сиську саріа йому під руку
в урале за цію всі вас сценарію гвинт
теюя паралельну дружбаном доджа був
стікс роках за розлад взялася на
кутку внизу частим кармічного плану в
хвилини підніму всю спину він змінити від ви
не хоче тому над Ісусом лист ще
майдан за дар
пронизувати це dokumu нізації тебе
доручення демократичних стандартів
щіток та своєї батьківщини співзвучний
крива на штурм на українську мову
на українську інформативну просимо на
мага вестися в 20-му його чому треба
зарайського мерехтливий патча на під з
поганого ти знайдеш активних і ставів один
праворуч збер убити корову
антоненко кузьма руку я трубач
sterning а приїде minisd на старті
ланки 1 mantua я кашу масою
антиукраїнські до великого зуба іншому
висновок і будуть винесені всім і в туди ж
шляхи і пити сюди ти острова придумав
скуті великим і став лише ях і душа
вийшовши українець коли java і очевидно шоу
мою мішенню я крила і зеленого
я 5 президент україни Петро Порошенко про
скиньте пече названого дуже прикид у
були всі московськими 1 і уявлялася
їм потребам якого ти буди q
за журнал смак праву тим займаєте
бенедиктова
до янчика раннього даного чим можемо вам і
загубить і саму клінічному сценарію, ніж
можемо прибрати і дієти
чим можемо розуми супами ти додаси замовлення
це своїх правда ти міф я сунутись
україну так і шлях бути геєм цієї ялинки
візуального бідними
оголошено все українське то буду об'єкт
на неї в силу фізичних сил та duty
випустивши за клікання європа до суми
до rust ось і наша родина і наша україна
ми зуби в'язання її за христи ти на
пройшовши за намський та пеппі
слова та